from across Lake Okanagan the fire
damage to West Kelowna is clear to see a
few nights ago this Shoreline was an
inferno it's one aspect of the worst
Wildfire year and Canada's recorded
history so far in 2023 more than 5 700
fires have broken out from Nova Scotia
in the East to British Columbia in the
west and the Yukon Territory far to the
North right now more than a thousand
fires are active and a quarter of them
are burning uncontrolled according to
Canada's fire agency an estimated 196
thousand people have been evacuated and
at least six have died nearly 140 000
square kilometers have burned scientists
say the global root cause of these
individual events is clear human-caused
global warming one of the common threads
for all of these fires is longer fire
Seasons more intense droughts and more
extreme stream fire weather the degree
of temperature the degree of drought and
the wind combining to drive these fires
all of which are linked to climate
change British Columbia's Premier noted
that it's a worldwide crisis the
ferocity of the fires uh the extent of
the burning the historic nature of the
forest fires we're seeing not just here
in British Columbia but in Greece in
Nova Scotia in the United States it's
just devastating fires that are clearly
linked to human-caused climate change
experts say the fires themselves are
making global warming worse when fires
burn it burns carbon in the trees and in
the soil and releases carbon dioxide and
other greenhouse gases into the
atmosphere that increase concentration
of of greenhouse gases in the atmosphere
creates the more extreme droughts and
makes the changes to our fire Seasons
which trigger more fires which release
more greenhouse gases so you can see how
this creates a positive feedback loop
burned forests and homes are a disaster
for people who live here but they're
also a sign that our planet is changing
rapidly with consequences for everyone
everywhere
Rob Reynolds Al Jazeera Kelowna British
Columbia
foreign